or après pour moi décroche
bonjour ça va je m'appelle bec
dougan scène tu fais quoi quand tu g pas
de yoga je distribue courrier le premier
facteur sur les braises j'espère ça ça
me plaît je sais que vous êtes tous des
alpinistes aguerris
sinon vous seriez pas ici mais les brest
c'est l'endroit le plus dangereux sur
terre
la vidéo très bonne j'aimerais être avec
toi mon doigt près ensemble la prochaine
fois tous les trois et aux femmes
elle va très bien depuis qu'on a divorcé
et bonjour tout le monde
tiens v'là le maire du camp de base
assieds toi qui m'as tu toi
les êtres humains ne sont pas conçus
pour fonctionner à l'altitude de
croisière d'un 747 nos corps vont
littéralement mourir
le jeu consiste donc à vous conduire au
sommet et à vous ramener en bas avant
que ça se produise
vingt mille histoires
lâche s'ouvre dans quelques jours et
pour toute ta vie tu seras titre qui est
arrivé au sommet de l'everest
rabouy du sommet de l'everest
ob répond ya des nuages qui monte de la
vallée beaucoup de nuages
oh non on a du monde bloqué là haut et
la tempe et de sa grave le problème n'a
plus d'oxygène louis continue donc je
n'abandonnerai pas
je peux pas mourir
tu m'entends
il porte une blouse vite
c'est quelqu'un peut y arriver c'est toi
je t'aime